[Music]
one of the most troubling issues exposed
by the covet 19 pandemic is the
widespread distrust of experts it turns
out that a significant portion of
americans regard vital medical and
scientific breakthroughs made by actual
doctors and scientists with a skepticism
bordering on denial and it's not good
when we ignore experts people die don't
believe me well it's been happening
since the beginning of time let me show
you with a quick trip to
the wall of people who [ __ ] we were not
trying to hear
this is a wall of geniuses who made
life-saving discoveries discoveries we
were not trying to hear like onesimus an
enslaved black man who introduced the
concept of inoculation to america during
the smallpox outbreak of 1721.
he said hey guess what
you can keep people from catching a
disease if you expose them to a very
small amount of the disease under the
supervision of a doctor
unfortunately the people of boston were
not trying to hear his [ __ ] so they
firebombed his master's house and then a
bunch of them caught smallpox and died
they showed him
oh by the way no photo of onesimus
exists so instead we took this photo of
waldo geraldo faldo from family matters
and we made it look old-timing
or something
something fun to do
now this is benjamin franklin you may
recognize him from money
franklin and his brother were hardcore
anti-vaxxers and they even printed and
distributed anti-vaxx pamphlets until
ben's own son who wasn't vaccinated died
of smallpox
franklin was devastated and spent the
rest of his life trying to convince
scientists and government health
agencies that people need to be
vaccinated did people listen no they
were not trying to hear his [ __ ]
next up there's hungarian physician
ignac
decades before the discovery of germs
some of ice was a doctor in a maternity
ward and he couldn't figure out why so
many of the young mothers under his care
kept dying but he had a suspicion he
thought
maybe the deaths have something to do
with doctors performing autopsies and
then right afterwards delivering babies
so he suggested a solution everyone
should just wash their hands and it
worked mothers stopped dying but oh my
god people lost it doctors were not
trying to hear that the number one cause
of death was their own nasty hands
so even though he was totally and
completely right people decided he was
crazy he was eventually committed to a
mental institution where the guards
broke his hands and he died
not from the broken hands but because a
cut on his broken hand got infected and
those [ __ ] literally wouldn't let
him wash his hands
it's real it sucks then it's real thank
you for your service ignaz but
unfortunately ain't nobody trying to
hear your [ __ ]
next up you know him you love him it's
german bacteriologist and hygienist carl
fluga
luga was the first person to suggest
that doctors wear so-called mouth
bandages during surgery to prevent tiny
droplets from flying out of their mouths
and into their patients bloodstreams
great idea carl he's credited with the
ins with inspiring the use of the first
surgical masks and the concept of social
distancing to avoid disease transmission
now at the time everyone said he was
dumb and
125 years later people still aren't
trying to hear his [ __ ] next up it's
former vice president al gore now
ellie now this
this sad sack has been trying to warn us
about the existential dangers of climate
change for the last 20 years and we just
blew him off
and now the world is literally on fire
sorry dude sorry hell man your [ __ ] was
so right but we were not trying to hear
it or how about dr anthony fauci
yeah baby
i mean we like him in this room but all
this guy's trying to do is save the
human race and 50 of the country thinks
he's the actual antichrist honestly i
can't believe he's still at it because
there are just so many people not trying
to hear his [ __ ]
on this wall it's lonely up here
but don't worry tony in a couple hundred
years people might realize you were
right fingers crossed so let's take a
look at all these magnificent faces
you can call them innovators you can
call them trailblazers
you can call them ahead of their
time the brothers best friend remember
what i call them
the wall of people who [ __ ] who were not
trying to
[Applause]
[Music]
you